(symphonic music)
- Snowshoes are designed
to help you maintain
the weight of your body on top of the snow
as opposed to sinking in.
And with every pair of
snowshoes, there's a story.
I'm Bill Mackowski, I’m a snowshoe
maker and a snowshoe collector.
Over the years, I've
collected over 200 pair.
As far as we know it's
the largest collection
of snowshoes in the world.
For Native Americans, snow
shoes were not a convenience,
they were critical.
An individual may have three or
four or five different pairs of shoes
that he used for different conditions.
There's a shoe for spring,
for deep fluffy snow,
for straight travel.
There's a wide range of designs.
I first got started using
snowshoes as a young fella.
I spent a good part of
my life in the woods,
trapping, fishing, and hunting.
In the mid-'80’s, I was
flying in northern Quebec
and came upon a winter
camp and found a pair
of traditional Native snow shoes.
Being a snowshoe maker
I had an appreciation
for the unbelievable
craftsmanship and skill
that went into making these
traditional snow shoes.
From that point I kind
of embarked on a quest
to find some of these
other villages that had
snowshoe makers.
I visited every native
community in Quebec,
in the Yukon, several in
the northwest territories,
in Ontario, Alaska and all
up and down the north shore
of St. Lawrence.
What I tried to do is to ask
them about their techniques.
Things like, how do you
know what kind of wood
you want to use, how do you
know which tree is right for the wires,
why do you have this
kind of a weave in it?
(buzzes)
(scrapes)
In the process of all this
documenting and visiting,
I learned a considerable amount
about crafting shoes myself.
It's given me just a
phenomenal appreciation for,
not only their skill but their lifestyle.
The primary focus at this point should be
to get this collection in a
situation where it's available
for people to study, for scholars,
and for people to see.
I know other people
have collected snowshoes,
but I don't think anyone has
ever done it on this scale.
I don't think it's anything
that could ever be done again,
simply because that skill is that lost.
It's really the last of the
traditional snowshoe makers.